це кінець навчального року
чудова нагода перевірити
знання англійської де це ой ой
там червоний квадрат так як далеко звідси
як далеко до червоного метрів далеко так що
це означає що це означає я такий
тобі подобається футбольний випуск середньої школи,
добре, вітаю, вітаю,
а тепер це пан.  Путін там,
отже, він працює в цьому офісі, так,
згідно з дослідженнями, лише близько 30
відсотків росіян володіють англійською
мовою
ти схожий на Сталіна так, дорогий, ти
розмовляєш англійською
ні ні англійською ні англійською Я покидаю Червону
площу та прямую до старої приблизно
знаменитої  вулиця в центрі Москви, коли я
отримаю спеціальний приз для США Special
1303 ти для мене, тому що я
іноземець, ці кадети покликані допомагати
людям, тому в основному йдіть у кінець
цієї вулиці так, так, і щось
заплановане правильно, і одні на  дорога
через дорогу, все добре, і йде
[Музика]
Це правда, багато росіян не розмовляють
англійською, але вони компенсують це
своєю гостинністю та щедрістю, що
розуміють люди в усьому світі
[Музика]